In the 18th century, it was all the rage to study electricity.
Everyone was doing it, and the thing they were storing their electricity in
was known as a Leyden jar.
Now, we don't need to go into the details of how this jar worked just yet,
but the key thing to know is that if there is a process which involved friction
this jar could become charged.
And for now, let's say that charged means the jar possesses electricity in some way.
Well once it was charged, the electrodes of this jar could be connected to wires
and by attaching these wires to various objects
you could see things like sparks or you could even start a fire.
Now remember, Benjamin Franklin's idea was that lightning is somehow
the same thing as the electricity that scientists
have been playing around with in these Leyden jars.
So my question is, which of the following options would be the most convincing
demonstration to show that lightning is actually the same thing
as the electricity in these Leyden jars?
Would we want to show that lightning, like a Leyden jar,
can actually somehow cause a fire?
Would we want to show that we can use lightning directly to charge a Leyden jar?
Would we want to use lightning to destroy a Leyden jar?
Or would we want to see if lightning somehow increases friction?
The thinking being that Leyden jars were somehow charged by a process that involve friction.
Which of these four options should Benjamin Franklin do
if he wants to convincingly prove that lightning is electricity?